hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome attacking game from round nine
of the 2019 single Cup at Ningaloo and
versus the Fabiana Caruana
really an exciting game so let's just
dive straight into it I think with the
white pieces opens with d4 with Knight
to f6 c4 and you won't know where this
is going east 6 sorry about that
with Knight to f3 and d5 the Queens
gambit the client is on the board with
Knight to c3 Bishop to e7 and now Bishop
to f4 with castles by Caruana now comes
a 3 & b6 now preparing to finca to the
light square Bishop Bishop to d3 and
only now after why to develop the light
square bishop D captures on c4 make wise
a white wasted tempo the shop capture
Sun see 4 and now Bishop to e6 offering
at the trade bishops and now you could
go
quinta e2 I believe this is what
Franklin played against Anand in the
Tata Steel in January but being prefers
Bishop captures on a6 or no Bishop to e2
is a known move but shank and also
captured in 86 against talent in the
Tata Steel tournament Knight captures an
a6 and the now Quinta e2 developing the
Queen while attacking the knight here
and Quinta c8 defending the knight with
castles by dink and here c5 is the only
move that was ever played in this
position one such a notable game is
Magnus Carlsen versus Hikaru Nakamura in
the 2018 world blitz championship in San
Pietro Berg but here we have Queen tabby
7 now it's a new move Khurana decides to
fianchetto the Queen instead prepare
rook to see it and then the c5 pawn will
have support from the rook and here we
have a 3 taking away the before square
from blacks pieces you don't wanna allow
tonight b4 to d5 to get this useless
night from a 6-2 such a nice square like
d5 with c5 by Caruana and now Knight the
b5 and here with the nights that efore
we would transpose into the course and
versus nakamura game that we've
mentioned but here rook 8 the CH this is
idea Caruana prepared for this game with
B for biding bringing more pressure to
the c5 square and now Knight to d5 going
after the bishop here B captaincy 5 this
was the his idea he doesn't mind Knight
captures on a4 there we would see a pawn
captures he captures the be kept Recife
and now look b1 developing while
threatening some discoveries but Khurana
says ok my knight on d5 is a good piece
I'm not really interested in your Bishop
on f4 I can always capture it and be
characters on c5 with rook 8 the be one
biting and now rook the c6 making room
for the other rook to enter the game but
also preparing rook to b6 the counter
things row can be one Bishop to e5 ding
now says ok you had your chance to grab
my there's a Plan F for now you can't
have it anymore and now you if you want
to get rid of it you're gonna have to
push them like f6 maybe you want to play
Bishop to f6 but you're definitely not
capturing but capturing by playing
Knight captures on f4 rook to b6 karana
continues with his plan and now a for
defending the knight with night 8 to c7
again pressuring the night here and now
the captures on c5 with Bishop captures
on c5 and now you cannot capture and c7
even though you're attacking the knight
twice because of rook captures and b1 so
here Dean finds the very nice rugby see
one gets away from all the pressure
along the B file and now puts pressure
along the C file you can't move the
bishop as then the knight 1 c7 would be
would be attacked three times so you
have to capture and e5 with knife
capture son b5 rook captures and c5 now
and now Knight back to d6 where the
knight is protected by the rook and Dean
continues pushing with a5 attacking the
rook Fabi plays rook to c6 offers the
rook trade but ding is not interested he
now wants to grab full control of the C
file and he does this by playing Bishop
captures and d6
so he forces a corona to recapture if
you captured the rook of course Bishop
just recaptures you lose a piece so
route captures and only now rook F the
c1 and now ding is the ruler supreme of
the C file
so we have h-65 we make some room for
the king
ding does the same with h3 and now rook
F to d8 as the C file is taken by ding
the 5e now grabs the D file we have
Knight to e5 which is an excellent
output since you're really not getting
rid of this night unless you want to
play something like f6 and you can't
really get rid of it with your own eye
for example 97 to g6 white just captures
it and ruins your pawn structure and
also you can go 97 to c6 as a white
controls the c6 square three times sorry
about that
so tonight's the f6 by Fabi and now
comes Knight to c6 really really awesome
active play by ding he's now preparing a
6 as the rook no longer controls the a6
squared rook 8 the b7 getting the rock
out of harm's way and now a6 attacking
the Queen with Queen to b6 and here
Knight back the e5 attacking the rook
once again rook to b8 and now rook the
c8 so what's what's the idea here
Queen to a5 by Fabi first going after
the knight on e5 and now f4 just you
know keeping everything in check asking
do you maybe wanna trade and see it
probably not interested for the moment
so rook to d2 a nice active move pushing
the Queen back Queen to f3
now the a6 pawn is no longer guarded but
first we have looked the d5 just getting
the room back with rook a I want the c7
and here the f7 pawn is under attack but
Khurana finds a very nice move King to
h7 and now you cannot capture the pawn
obviously we cannot capture with the
route because you lose the rook and see
it but if you capture with the night
it's no better you get rook to d1 check
King to h2 and now Queen to II 1 and
there's really nothing you can do about
Queen g1 I mean it's not a win it's a
draw because after all I say rook
captures here you get Queens you want
checking here King to g3 and now Queen
back to e1 check and now you have to
repeat the King H to King's you speak
English to pin g3 because if you play
Queen f2 you block then 94 check for the
Queen and the wins the game for black so
after
h7 you cannot capture on f7 ding goes
clink to h2 not allowing any checks
looking as much safer there
and now rook captures in c8 we have rook
captures and finally Fabi grabs the a6
pawn queen captures on a6 so for the
moment Fabi is up a pawn but dink has
something else to say about it
rook to e8 also an interesting move was
Luke to f8 going after the f7 pawn the
thing is after night study sorry after
night the d7 attacking the rook and the
night you play Knight captures rook
captures and Queenie forecheck and now
this was the idea both both players
missed but you know just would be a very
boring game if no one missed anything
because after f5 you can simply capture
rook captures on f5 and now you're
threatening some nasty discoveries also
this would be a nice nasty discovery
because after he captures and if I were
just captured with Czech queen g6 block
check now you pick up the rook here
you're up a pawn with a very nice
position but ding plays rook to e8 it's
never too early to put put a rug behind
the passed pawn queen b7 attacking the
rook and now rook to f8 and rook to b5
offering a queen trade so now I would
you play here for example you could try
rook captures on f7 to go for a queen
trade but this is what Bobby wanted
Queen captures Knight captures and a5
and you have this position working the
material on the board is equal but black
has a passed a 5 point it's hard to say
if you can push it right away White has
some 94 to e6 ideas where you will put a
lot of pressure on the Kings side so you
can go Knight to d5 just go after the e3
pawn and this is much safer and nothing
for whites to look for there so dingos
Queen to f1 avoiding the Queen trait is
still keeping the threat of rook
captures on f7 and Knight captures an f7
on the board we have Queen to d5 and now
comes Knight captures on f7 if rook
captures on f7 then looked a b7 it's
nice and nice position for black for
example rook captures Queen captures and
now you get Queen d3 check Queen to b4
you block check and now you have the
outside passport even if white raids why
doesn't trade us really
the outside past bond will always be
very strong
so after Queen d5 we have night captures
on f7 biding ended now tonight the b7
pushing the road back rook to b8 pinning
the night and now rook to b8 forcing a
rogue trade with rook captures Knight
captures and now Queen to be one check
connecting nicely with the knight on b8
you don't want a piece because well you
can just block with Queen to f5 it's
interesting if King g8 then black black
loses the game because first you capture
on h6 with check and after we capture
capture with check after this you grab
this pawn with check for points 2 2 this
will be winning for white so instead
after Queen b1 check for place Quinta f5
now after the Queen recapture the night
here you will be guarding the a7 pawn
and it's interesting what didn't place
here feel free to pause the video and
try to find the best continuation for
white in this position while I give you
a couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent lifter of Queens now
and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy Queen b7 is the best idea if you
capture the knight then we already said
Queen captures the SMN ponies card but
here now you're definitely asking black
what do you want to do here and it's not
all that easy for example if you push a
5 just 96 or 98 and how do you save the
night there's no saving this night it
can't go anywhere and the Queen is
unable to protect the knight next the
move you're just gonna capture it and
it's game over
so here Bob finds 96 and okay now you
capture black just captures back we get
the pretty much the same idea where
wording is very happy you could grab a
pawn here with Knight captures on h6 and
then recapture on c6 but dink continues
with an even better move Knight d6
again black has to defend the knight on
c6 otherwise you're down a piece Queen
to c5 is played and now Knight to e4
asking again what do you want to do if
you move the Queen away from the
protection of the night then just Queen
captures and you guard a de for tonight
so it's not a problem you have to be
careful if you play something like not a
queen
five you get night of six check and you
lose the queen since the G pawn is
pinned so here probably the best idea
for for Fabi in this situation is Queen
captures and III just give up the night
and then go Queen Queen a4 check the
problem is white has g3 and you have no
more checks this is covered by the
knight discovered by the knight
if Queen f1 then Queen c2 again you
guard against any checks and you're also
threatening some discoveries and you do
have two points for a knight but you
know like Tao says a night is a night so
Fabi doesn't like his chances here he
plays Queen to c2 still keeping an eye
on this night here but now Dean has a
different idea which also is very nice
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the winning move for ding in
this position while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent checker with a knight and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show Knight to f6 check and now of
course you see that King h8 is
impossible due to Quincy 8 mate well
once you block check and then it's mate
the night covers aged 7 so Bobby had to
play King to g6 but now who an IT 8 and
nice to eat is just as winning but even
crazier was Knight to h5 a threatening
the same idea Queen captures here and if
you capture the knight then Queen
captures and g7 threatening mate here
and well very soon black will run out of
most Queen e2 you garden made button
Queen f7 check King gauge for Queen g6
Czech threatening to capture here and
there's no defense against this if you
move the Queen from the second rank then
g3 is mate so this was a one possibility
but being found Knight to e8 which works
just as fine it's not as aesthetically
pleasing but you know you're about to
beat Fabiana Khurana you don't need it
to be aesthetically pleasing
Queen to c3 guarding g7 but now comes he
for preparing a5 to block the Queen's
defence of the g7 pawn so a5 Fabi sees
that there is nothing to be done here he
just starts starts pushing his past pawn
we have Queen to d7 going after each six
still keeping an eye on the night here
Fabi continues pushing the past pawn
knock on screen captures an a6 check
King to h7 and now II five blocking the
defense of the or of the g7 pawn here
nights the d4 attacking the Queen and
now Queen d7 threatening mate
so King to g6 there's no way to defend
the pawn and now Queen captures and g7
with check with King to f5 and not
Knight to d6 check and now if you go
King e6 then Queen f7 is made again we
have this very nice structure that we
often mentioned which you should
remember if you if you're a beginner it
will be much easier for you to to locate
checkmates on the board so King captures
an f4 is played but now Queen to f6
check King to e3 Fabi escapes with a
sting but now comes a six the thread is
just e 7 and e 8 Queen King to d3
getting out of the e-file but it doesn't
matter East 7 and it was in this
position on mu 57 that Fabiana Caruana
resigned the game as there are no tricks
there are no checks there are no
attempts here next move is just a e8
Queen and then you can just do whatever
you want so there's no point in
continuing this game so an excellent win
by doing we're not gonna show the
standings just yet as there is another
game I wanna show from round 9 so we're
gonna discuss the standings in the
tournament a bit after that video which
will follow shortly after this one yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Stefan Vale for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos
sure thank all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the simple Cup
continue in the Capablanca saga checking
up on your suggestions and I will show
the Bangko versus tile game that you
have requested during the Toliver
special video so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day